my next guest has sparked a national
debate on the conventional wisdom about
african-americans in politics well
Candace Owens has urged black voters to
think independently for themselves and
to question liberal orthodoxy
she has been mercilessly attacked online
but coming to her defense very
interestingly has been hip-hop star
Kanye West well he tweeted on Saturday I
love the way Candace Owens thinks she
punking all of us what's going on with
that as we shared with you last night a
hip-hop radio host also claims that West
told him that he loves President Trump
and he likes Owens because she's
challenging conventional Black Thought
joining me now to respond to the
controversy is candice owens herself hey
Candace how are ya
I'm doing great thank you for having me
well lately you just go to a college
campus and you start talking about think
for yourself and be your own person and
gosh that's kind of a me-too thing like
stand up for yourself don't be a victim
I was listening to I didn't see who it
was and I thought oh it's like a me-too
thing that I saw oh it's Owen wait a
second why is it so controversial were
you surprised that this became you know
such a big deal obviously Kanye weighs
in but were you surprised I actually
wasn't surprised at all this is what
I've been talking about across college
campuses with Turning Point USA is that
there is this liberal indoctrination
they think that they have a monopoly not
just on our students which is what we
deal with that Turning Point USA but
also on the entire black race in America
they cannot fathom that we might have
different ideas they don't understand
because they they have significantly
created a mental prison for all of us
and the second somebody runs off what I
refer to as a democratic plantation they
send the dogs out well there was an
interesting moment on this radio show
the skyyy bro who's a very interesting
host and he was talking about kanye west
and he was saying well Connie is not
thinking independently because he lives
himself in a bubble let's watch Kanye is
talking about things that don't affect
him they do not let's be honest none of
things affect him he lives in a bubble
where it's like none of us could really
understand all he's surrounded by is the
Kardashians and a bunch of yes men and
the fashion world and this he doesn't
understand what's happening in in in the
streets what's happening in when it
comes to protest none of that oh wait a
second as if there aren't
multi-millionaire african-americans
Latinos and others living in bel air
brentwood malibu i mean because you
don't live on the streets then you can't
comment on anything
well that's drying in the Kardashians
what was going on with that comment it
just wasn't a very smart comment is when
it comes down to it was a fallacious
argument that could be attacked a
thousand different ways I mean to
suggest that because somebody has money
they can't think or they don't have any
knowledge or facts or data makes
entirely no sense in fact you could
argue that they may have more access to
those things so I thought that was just
incredibly just low IQ is what it really
comes down to and at the end of the day
these radio hosts not the great
philosophers of our time they do what
they do they get on there and they try
to stir up the controversy they talk
about the story of a day and they're
incapable of thinking critically well
I'm a radio host and I talk about the
subjects of the day as well but I didn't
do it with some degree of knowledge and
experience Candace where you going next
you know I'm gonna keep doing what I'm
doing I'm gonna keep punching back I
have zero fear when it comes this guy
knew exactly that this was going to be
the blowback I know that you recently
had some experience with this you
understand mob mentality and the result
is it usually has adverse results that's
exactly what we see with your show why
it's been so spectacular and I'm hoping
we're gonna see the exact same thing in
the black community you create a
conflict at the end of the day it ends
up waking up more people to an
underlying problem which is the fact
that we don't have enough diversity of
thoughts within the black community all
right thanks so much Candace